all right golden knights back at work
last night they resumed their Stanley
Cup Quest it is their old tricks round
two of the playoffs for Vegas they
hosted Edmonton for a wild game one Ron
Futrell joins us live here this morning
with the highlights Ron good morning to
you sir good morning John good morning
Heather no robots last night okay just a
wild game at T-Mobile Arena 10 goals
scored in this one here we go fun night
everybody excited about this one one of
the story lines to watch in this series
is the Oilers power play historic it's
best in NHL history tonight's got to
figure out a way to slow down oh we got
a dry settle first goal of the game on a
power play one nothing Edmonton Knights
counter with three straight goals that's
best way to beat a power play Mark Stone
one of his own 3-1 knights in the first
then there's this tri-sidle again
did that go out the back
of Lauren brochois I think it did
more on that in a moment okay so we're
tied
early in the third
Ivan barbashev two goals here's his
second to give the lights a lead at this
point then about a minute later Chandler
Stevenson for the knights puts one home
nice get a 6-4 win to open the series
it's been after after mine it was only
two and uh you know they say that's
where it's late in hockey but
um yeah they uh you know they don't quit
they got two of the best players in the
world over there especially at home I
mean we tried to take advantage of the
break we had here and uh tried to
get our legs under us
um you know sometimes having a week off
is a little tough but
um yeah I mean to get that uh two goals
yeah it's definitely a little bit of
insurance but at the same time uh like
we're saying earlier it's just you know
you're still playing the Oilers
they are still and they are still
playing the Oilers four o'clock Saturday
will be game two in this series okay the
goal off the back there John you got an
email from Gordon as did I yeah he
didn't send it to Heather because
Heather already knows this information
Eiserman perfected that back in the day
with the Red Wings Gretzky did it quite
a bit too the goal off the back well
Gretzky used to can't balance behind
them that was where he was his office
yes but I feel like nowadays there are
more players that are trying that off
the back of the goalie shot from behind
the net it's not easy to do but it's
cool have you done it no I played you've
tried I get mad when they do it chase
them down you start a fight I hope oh
yeah and usually lose again four o'clock
Saturday game two this series is going
to be a fun one I think for Knights fans
let's start off well ten past two